IN THE O'DONNELL.
HERE O'DONNELL HERE KALRA.
KALRA HERE HIGHLY.
KILEY HERE MCCARTY [inaudible]
SMITH.
IT HERE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
THANK YOU A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED I'D LIKE TO WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THIS
AFTERNOON'SHEARING.
WE HAVE ONE BILL ON FILE TODAY
SB.
ONE TWENTY SIX BY US SENATOR
LEYVA AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL ME.
BUT OUR FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
TODAY IS TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY SESSION.
THE RULES HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS OFFICES
IN ADVANCE --
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
REGARDING THE COMMITTEE RULES.
HEARING NO DISCUSSION WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD DO I HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ON THE RULES.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY.
MISTER KALRA AND SECONDED BY
DOCTOR WEBER.
OF MISS SMITH I'M SORRY MISS
SMITH I APOLOGIZE.
OKAY I'M --
A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
I DON'T KNOW I KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY NO [inaudible]
KILEY NO [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
SMITH [inaudible]
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE WILL TO NUMBER FORTY
ONE ARE GOING FORWARD IF THE
VOTE IS FORTY ONE THOSE RULES
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED --
BY A VOTE OF THIS COMMITTEE WITH
THAT WE WITH THAT WE ARE READY
TO HEAR OUR ONE MEASURE TODAY --
SP ONE TWENTY SIX WILL FIRST
HEAR.
FROM --
SENATOR LEYVA ON SB ONE TWENTY
SIX YOU MAY PROCEED ONE READY.
THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
SB ONE TWENTY SIX ENSURES THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS COMPLY WITH THE
SAME TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY LAWS THAT ALL OF
OUR OTHER PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CURRENTLY FOLLOW.
AS YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR
RECENTLY CALLED FOR SWIFT ACTION
TO RESOLVE ONGOING CHARTER
SCHOOL TRANSPARENCY ISSUES WELL
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE UNIQUE IN
MANY WAYS.
THEIR PUBLICLY FUNDED AND YET
THEY LACK THE SAME TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY REQUIREMENTS
THE GOVERNOR OTHER PUBLICLY
FUNDED EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
UNDER THIS BILL CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS WILL BE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH THE SAME
OPEN MEETING CONFLICT OF
INTEREST AND DISCLOSE DISCLOSURE
DISCLOSURE.
LAWS AS TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT MEMBERS OF CHARTER
SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS CANNOT
USER POSITIONS FOR PERSONAL OR
POLITICAL GAME. FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
ATTEMPTED TO BRING CLARITY TO
THIS ISSUE FORTUNATELY OUR
ATTORNEY GENERAL RECENTLY
PUBLISHED AN OPINION CLEARLY
STATING THAT YES THESE GOOD
GOVERNMENT LAWS DO APPLY TO
CHARTER SCHOOL GOVERNING BOARDS.
WHILE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OPINION PROVIDE SOME MUCH NEEDED
CLARITY ON WHETHER OR NOT THESE
LAWS APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOL
GOVERNING BOARDS.
THE OPINION IS NOT LEGALLY
BINDING.
ABSENT THE MEASURE BEFORE YOU
TODAY WHICH CODIFIES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OPINION
DISPUTES WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
ACROSS THE STATE OVER HOW THESE
LAWS APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS.
MEMBERS SB ONE TWENTY SIX SIX
REFLECTS OUR BY CAMEL RESPONSE
TO THE GOVERNOR'S CALL FOR
ACTION.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED BY TEACHERS
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS LABOR AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS THE
CALIFORNIA'S CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION REMAINS NEUTRAL AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR I WILL NOW
TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO MR KILEY
FOR A BRIEF MOMENT HERE.
AND I WALKED DOWN PRESENT
[inaudible]
PLEASE STILL [inaudible]
AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
PROCEED.
YOU MIGHT THANK YOU.
I AM PLEASED TO BE A JOINT
AUTHOR OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THIS IS A GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL
IT APPLIES GOOD GOVERNMENT LOST
TO CHARTER SCHOOL OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE LEARNING
CENTERS NOT PROFIT CENTERS.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
THE USE OF OUR PRECIOUS FEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL DOLLARS ARE
SUBJECT TO TRANSPARENCY.
COMMON ETHICAL PRACTICES AND
GOOD GOVERNMENT LAW THAT IS
APPLIED TO OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
OPERATIONS ACROSS OUR STATE.
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
HAS BEEN SHARED HAS VERY
RECENTLY OPINED THAT THESE LAWS
DO APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS BUT
THIS BILL PROVIDES ADDED CLARITY.
THIS BILL PROTECTS PRESSURES
EDUCATION DOLLARS WHICH SHOULD
BE USED FOR STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS
NOT PROFITS.
THE LIST OF CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
THE HISTORY FISCAL MISMANAGEMENT
IS LONG CELERITY MAGNOLIA AND
TRY VALLEY LEARNING CORPORATION
ARE JUST A FEW.
IT HAS BEEN THE WILD WEST IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S FAR WITH
REGARD TO THESE DOLLARS.
INTO -- NOW
THESE SCHOOLS HAVE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF PUBLIC MONEY BUT NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IN FACT.
HAVE ARGUED THAT A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST OR LACK OF ENTRANCED
RANTS PERRANCE HE WAS ACTUALLY
ALLOWABLE.
UNDER THE LAW.
LOCALLY ELECTED PUBLIC SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SUBJECT
TO TRANSPARENCY AND ETHICAL
STANDARDS SO TOO SHOULD CHARTER
SCHOOL OPERATIONS.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL MEASURE TO PROTECT ALL
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS.
THANK YOU SIR.
MISTER VICE CHAIR OF THEM IN
SUPPORT.
YES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS SETH
BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE SENATE
BILL. ONE TWO SIX CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
WERE ESTABLISHED WITH THE
PROMISE WILL GIVE YOU THE
FREEDOM TO INNOVATE AND YOU'LL
SHOW US RESULTS LIKE LIGHT
HOUSES THEY WERE PLACE WHERE WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO SOMETHING A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
AND THEN APPLY --
ANYTHING WE'VE LEARNED ACROSS
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION I WAS
EXCITED TO HEAR FROM THE CHARTER
SCHOOL DIVISION DIRECTOR IN
OAKLAND UNIFIED ABOUT A SYSTEM
HE CALLED.
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER WHERE THE
PRINCIPLES THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND THE PRINCIPLES THAT
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
COME TOGETHER AND SHARE BEST
PRACTICES AND THAT'S WHAT WAS
INTENDED HERE LESSONS LEARNED.
BUT THE PEOPLE CANNOT LEARN FROM
THIS INNOVATION IF THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS AND CAN IS CONDUCTED IN
PRIVATE --
WE DID NOT INTEND --
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS TO DO AS
THEY WISH WITH PUBLIC FUNDS --
TO THE CONTRARY WE INSIST ON
RETAINING CONTROL AND ON STAYING
INFORMED THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH NOT US THE
PUBLIC YIELDING CONTROL TO THE
AGENCIES THAT SERVE US --
HAVING PRIVATE AND SECRET
MEETINGS ABOUT HOW TAX DOLLARS
ARE BEING SPENT IS NOT
INNOVATION IT DOES NOT BENEFIT
THE SYSTEM AND IN FACT IT'S
RESULTED IN A NUMBER OF COURSE
STORIES AS A MISTER CHAIR
MENTIONED --
WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS --
BY ALL MEANS DO WHAT YOU WANT
BUT DO IT OUT IN THE OPEN WHERE
EVERYONE CAN SEE I CAN CERTAINLY
PROVIDE YOU EXAMPLES OF SOME OF
THESE --
HORROR STORIES IF THE COMMITTEE
DESIRES BUT SURELY WHAT THIS
BILL IS SAYING IS YOU KNOW TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS IS DREAM BIG AND
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX BUT DON'T
ABUSE THE PUBLIC TRUST AND SPEND
THAT MONEY ON OUR STUDENTS
PUBLIC EDUCATION MUST BE.
ABOUT KIDS NOT PROFITS WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOUR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARLOS MACHADO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION.
CSPA HAS BEEN WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS --
THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN A PRIORITY
FOR BOTH ON THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARDS AND ALSO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION BOARDS --
MADE CHARTERS ARE ALREADY
FOLLOWING.
THESE RULES --
IN THESE CASES AUTHORIZES OF
WORK COOPERATIVELY WITH CHARTER
PETITIONERS AYE TO CHIEF
COMPLIANCE UNFORTUNATELY IN SOME
INSTANCES SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS.
AREN'T COMPLYING --
AND THE AUTHORIZED OR DOESN'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY AT THIS POINT
IN ORDER TO COMPEL THAT
COMPLIANCE --
ED [inaudible]
SEE -- SB
YOU -- ONE
TWENTY SIX WOULD CREATE SOME
CONSISTENCY AROUND THIS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND OUT IN.
ENSURE THAT PARENTS AND STUDENTS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN DECISION MAKING PROCESS I AT
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ARE THE FACT THAT SOME CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY AND HEARING
TO THE STATUTES NOW --
INDICATES THAT COMPLIANCE WOULD
NECESSARILY BE A PROBLEM FOR ME
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS OUT THERE.
ARE THE BILL WOULD ENSURE THE
CHARTERS SCHOOLS FOLLOW THE
BASIC REQUIREMENTS AND HELP
IMPROVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR IT.
AUTHORIZES BOTH AT THE COUNTY
AND AT SCHOOL DISTRICT LEVEL --
AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
INCREASE PARENT AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT --
HAVING THESE.
A STATUTES IN PLACE WOULD ENSURE
THAT PARENTS AND STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO PUBLIC RECORDS HAVE
ACCESS TO MEETINGS AND CAN THAT --
ENSURE THAT THAT THE DECISION
MAKERS AT THE CHARTER SCHOOL
AREN'T OF IMPACTED BY ANY
CONFLICTS.
OF FOR THESE REASONS THE SBA
SUPPORTS SB ONE TWENTY SIX AND
YOU THIS --
TO BASSETT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
WILL HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AT UNDER
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AND WE
HAVE THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS.
AND THE SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION THINK.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE SCHOOL EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON
RAPID BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
SAREK KAMINSKI CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
I'M NOT IS LEBRON LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
ARE YOU STILL THE FIRST
SCIENTIFIC A NETWORK OF CHARTER
OPPORTUNITY THREE ENGAGE IN
SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE TO MY MOVE BY MISTER KALRA.
WE HAVE A SECOND --
MISTER MCCARTY A SECOND BILL --
AND NOW WE'RE GONNA GO I THINK
WE WERE GOING TO SOMETHING
UNUSUAL SOMETHING I PROBABLY
DON'T IN HER TOO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA LET THE NEUTRAL POSITION --
SPEAK.
AND YOU GUYS AND IF YOU'VE BEEN
AROUND THE COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
THAT I DON'T USUALLY LET THE
NEUTRAL SPEAK PATES ALL
DIFFERENT.
SO WITH THAT.
ALL PROCEED RESHAPE THAT AT
APPRECIATE THE FLEXIBILITY
MISTER CHAIR I WILL NOT ABUSE IT
NOT EVERYBODY IF.
I **** SO I'M.
OR NOT IN A LESS THAN WHAT I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY IN THE BALANCE
OF MY TIME REVIEWING SOME OF THE
MISS CARE.
MIS CHARACTERIZATIONS THAT IN
OUR OPINION YOU FOR TODAY ABOUT
OUR SECTOR --
BUT PLEASE KNOW THAT WE ARE
NEUTRALITY IS NOT A TACIT --
CONSENT TO SOME OF THE RHETORIC
THAT YOU'RE HEARING BUT WE DO
WANT TO REINFORCES THAT AT CCS A
IN THE SECTOR.
HAS LONG BEEN ON RECORD PERRANCE
SEE -- WITH
OPEN MEETINGS AND PUBLIC RECORDS --
AS YOU ALL KNOW THE GOVERNMENT
TEN NINETY ISSUE HAS BEEN PRETTY
CONTENTIOUS FOR US BUT WE'RE
REALLY PROUD THAT WE BELIEVE
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO RESOLVE.
A LOT OF OUR ISSUES IN THE
AGREEMENT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN LEADERS
TAKEN A LEADERSHIP ROLE ON AND
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF YOU IS A BALANCED
AND COMPREHENSIVE RESOLUTION.
TO WHAT HAS BEEN VEXING AND LONG
STANDING DEBATE ON ON THIS ISSUE --
AND WHILE WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
BRING OURSELVES TO SUPPORTING
THE LEGISLATION. FOR FOR FOR
SOME REASONS THAT I WON'T BORE
YOU WITH TODAY --
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T LEND
ITSELF TO GETTING EVERYTHING YOU
WANT BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
MAJOR RESERVATIONS THAT WOULD
KEEP US FROM --
YOU KNOW MAKING THE ARGUMENT
THAT THE LEGISLATION SHOULD IN
ADVANCE TODAY THREE COULD
THROUGH COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU UP.
ANY OTHERS IN NEUTRAL.
OKAY GREAT --
WITH THAT WILL HAVE THE
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD.
IF SOMEONE COULD CLEAR THE WAY
FOR THE OPPOSITION TO BE MOST
APPRECIATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CAPITAL
HALLORAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER.
CAN I AM HERE IN OPPOSITION
TODAY AND OF COURSE WE ARE NOT
OPPOSED TO TRANSPARENCY.
IN GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENT
TRANSPARENCY IN CHARTER SCHOOLS --
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
NOT THE SAME AS WITH APPLY TO
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS.
I SIT ON A TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
BOARD AND SO I'M FAMILIAR WITH
SOME OF THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
AND I JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT
SOME OF THE DISCREPANCIES.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL IS OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE --
FOR INSTANCE I THINK THAT IT
LIMITS PARENTAL INVOLVEMENT WHEN
YOU DON'T ALLOW SCHOOLS CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO MEET AT DIFFERENT
SITES -- THE
SCHOOL BOARD THAT I SIT ON WE
PRIDE OURSELVES IN BOARD
MEETINGS ARE NOT PARTICULARLY
ENTERTAINING AND WE REALLY WORK
TO GET FOLKS INVOLVED IN AT OUR
MEETINGS.
SO WE REACH OUT AND GO TO A
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SITES THIS
PROHIBITS CHARTER SCHOOLS FROM
DOING THAT AND THAT SEEMS
PARTICULARLY PUNITIVE AND AND
SORT OF OPPOSITE OF WHAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
IN ADDITION OTHER THE
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL BOARD I SAID
WE DO IN FACT BROADCAST OUR
MEETINGS BUT THERE ISN'T A TWO
WAY --
REQUIREMENT AND SO WHEN WE
POSTED ONLINE THERE'S ONLY THE
TRANSMISSION OF WHAT FOLKSY FROM
OUR BROADCAST.
THE IDEA THAT SOME OF OUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE MULTIPLE
OUTLETS THE COST OF HAVING TO DO
ALL OF IT TO A TRANSMISSION
RECORDED AND THEN POSTED.
WE THINK IS PARTICULARLY ONEROUS
IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO GET
REIMBURSED FOR STATE MANDATES.
SO IT'S AN ADDITIONAL COST IT'S
AN ADDITIONAL --
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL COST AND
SOMETHING THAT THAT --
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND
DON'T HAVE TO COMPLY WITH SO
IT'S REALLY NOT THE SAME AS
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS --
AND SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
THINK THAT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS BILL
AND YET ANOTHER WAY THAT CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT CONSIDERED
PUBLIC AGENCIES --
IN IN THE WAY THAT TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS ARE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION --
TO MISTER CHEN MEMBERS MATTHEW
CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
ELECTION OFFICIALS.
WE FALL.
SORT PROBABLY OUTSIDE OF THE THE
GENERAL SCOPE OF SITTING THROUGH
NUMEROUS ROUND TABLE DISCUSSIONS
AND MANY HOURS OF DISCUSSION ON
THIS BILL FOR ARE VERY SMALL
PIECE.
OF THE WE WERE TRACKING BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE MINISTER THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT.
WHICH MY CLIENTS ADMINISTER --
OR OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE --
WE THINK THAT.
WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS BEING SUBJECT TO THE
POOR GIRL FOR MAX --
PERIOD BUT THERE ARE MOMENTS
WITHIN THE EDUCATION CO THE
DICTATE THE MINISTRATION OF MY
CLIENTS WOULD HAVE TO A CHANGE
SPECIFIC THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
OTHER WITH THE BRING THIS TO AN
OPPOSE POSITION WE RECOMMEND
THAT THOSE.
SPECIFICS BE STRUCK IN FROM THE
BILL AND CHARTER SCHOOLS BE.
SUBJECT TO THE PORTAL FOR MAX
PERIOD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SEE NO OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
BEHIND THE COMMITTEE WE DO HAVE.
A MOTION AND A SECOND --
AND DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENT FROM
ANY OF THE MEMBERS [inaudible]
WEBER.
IF THE VERYHAS COME UNDER
QUESTION RAISE YOUR HAND TO SOME
SO I KNOW THEY HAVE A RIGHT
THERE.
SMITH IF I DON'T SEE IT I DON'T
KNOW SO.
WHY GOT THE SNAP MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT?
GO FORWARD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AS
WELL AS SENATOR LEYVA FOR
AUTHORING --
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE I WILL
START BY SAYING THAT I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB ONE
TWENTY SIX A VERY MUCH LIKE THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY ALL SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS SHOULD FIRST AND
FOREMOST PROTECT THE STUDENTS
AND THE TAXPAYERS THEY SERVE.
AS A DUTY I TOOK VERY SERIOUSLY
AS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER WHO
ALWAYS HELD MEETINGS IN PUBLIC
ANNOUNCED IN ADVANCE --
WITH THE LOCATION --
SO THAT PARENTS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS OF ALL GOVERNANCE ALL
PARENTS AND STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THEIR SCHOOL
GOVERNANCE IN OPEN TO DISCLOSE
MEETINGS ALL PARENTS AND
STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR VOICES
ARE HEARD AND ACCOUNTED.
FOR THIS BILL TAKES THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS SUNSHINE AND DISCLOSURE
IN THE GOVERNANCE PROCESS THE
SAME SUNSHINE THAT SHOULD
REQUIRED BE REQUIRED OF ALL
ENTITIES THAT SERVE THE PUBLIC
ESPECIALLY OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS WISHING TO SPEAK.
YEAH QUITE --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I I
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO THANK --
OF THE AUTHORS FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD --
BUT THOSE HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR A
LITTLE WHILE KNOW THAT THE ISSUE
OF MEETINGS IN TRANSPARENCY AND
ALL THE KINDS OF THINGS AT
AFFILIATED WITH IT.
HAVE HAD A VERY LONG AND
STRUGGLING HISTORY OF IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO GET SOME AGREEMENT
AND UNDERSTANDING.
AND I'M APPRECIATIVE OF THE FACT
THAT -- THAT
THE GOVERNOR --
BASICALLY OF PUSH THIS THROUGH --
IT WITH SOME --
BALANCE I THINK IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST WHAT WE SEE TODAY SO.
I THINK IT DOES IT IT BUT IT
STRIKES A BALANCE THERE ARE
STILL SOME ISSUES I THINK THAT
NEED TO BE RESOLVED AS POINTED
OUT -- I
THINK OUR SCHOOLS SCHOOLS SHOULD
HAVE THE SAME STANDARDS.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ATTEMPTING TO DO --
AND YET OF SOMEONE BRINGS FOR TO
US SOME THINGS WHICH I KNOW ARE
NOT ALWAYS TRUE BECAUSE I WAS ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD AND WE DID MEET
IN DIFFERENT SITES BECAUSE EVERY
NOW AND THEN WANT TO GO TO A
DIFFERENT SCHOOL A DIFFERENT
PLACE.
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY TO BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER BOOK BOARD
MEETING SO THE FACT THAT IF
YOU'RE RESTRICTING FOLKS FROM
HAVING MEETINGS OF IN ONE PLACE
IT BECOMES DIFFICULT.
AND WHEN WE DO DO OF A TELEVISED
OF THINGS FOR SCHOOL BOARD IS
NOT TO WAY.
SO THAT COULD BE A DIFFICULT
PIECE AND I I HOPE PEOPLE LOOK
AT THAT BEFORE IT GOES TO THE
FLOOR TO SEE IF THERE'S SOME CUT
COMBINATIONS THAT CAN BE MADE.
EITHER IN OUR BUDGET --
SITUATION BECAUSE WE
OCCASIONALLY DO FUND MANDATES OF
BY CHARTERS WE MAKE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT BASICALLY BEING
OVERLY BURDENSOME TO CHARTER
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY'RE DIFFERENT
AND WE CAN CREATE THESE NEW
RULES.
WHEN IN REALITY IF THEY SHOULD
BE TREATED LIKE THE REGULAR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WITH A KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY
THAT ALL PARENTS WANT FROM THEIR
SCHOOLS --
SO I'M PLEASED THAT THAT WE'VE
DONE THAT I HOPE THAT BEFORE
THIS GOES TO THE FLOOR THAT
THERE IS AN HONEST EFFORT TO
LOOK AT THOSE TWO ISSUES.
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED BECAUSE
THEY ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES AND
THEY DO DISTINGUISH CHARTIST
MOTHERS IN TERMS OF HAVING
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE OWNERS --
LIKE EVERY SCHOOL I THINK IT
LIKE I SAID THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WORK THAT WE'VE DONE HERE --
I WOULD --
PROBABLY TONE DOWN THE RHETORIC
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW HORRIBLE
CHARGES ARE OR EITHER HEALTH HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS FOR OF ALL THE
THINGS THAT TAKE PLACE BECAUSE
IF YOU'VE BEEN AROUND SCHOOLS
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF TIME YOU
KNOW THAT THAT STUFF IS
APPLICABLE TO ALMOST.
ALL OF THE SCHOOLS AND NOT JUST
TO CHARTERS IN TERMS OF MONEY
AND WHERE GOALS AND SCHOOLS THAT
ARE IN RECEIVERSHIP AND NOT IN
RECEIVERSHIP AND WERE HAVING
DIFFICULTY IN BANKRUPTCY.
I MEAN IT'S JUST GOES ON AND ON
AND AND THERE'S A LOT NOT BLAME
TO GO AROUND --
WITHOUT ACTUALLY FOCUSING ON ONE
SIDE WOULD HATE FOLKS TO THINK
THAT THIS IS PARTICULARLY
DESIGNED BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT THE SCHOOLS THAT.
HAVE GONE AWRY --
IT IT GOING ON IN THE SCHOOLS
AND IT SHOULD BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION I TAKES PLACE ALL
THE TIME.
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT
OF CHARTER STUFF COMING FOR THIS
YEAR BY UNDERSTANDING PEOPLE
TELL ME.
I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S FORMED A
COMMITTEE --
TO BASICALLY DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE I'M OPTIMISTIC AND I KNOW
HE HAD A HAND IN THIS BUT I AM
OPTIMISTIC AND HOPEFUL.
THAT -- MANY
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
BEEN FACING IN THIS UNNECESSARY
BATTLE FOR THE LAST.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YEARS NOW
WILL HOPEFULLY BE RESOLVED TO A
BALANCE COMMITTEE --
THAT WE WILL GET SOME GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT AS A COMMITTEE OF IT.
THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN BOTH
HOUSES THAT WE WOULD MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO WAIT TO GET THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BEFORE WE MOVE
FOR WITH A LOT OF LEGISLATION.
I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT SUBJECT.
ALL OVER THE PLACE AND AND IF
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A BLUE
RIBBON COMMITTEE THAT'S LOOKING
AT CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE SHOULD TRY TO DO OUR BEST TO
WAIT TO SEE WHAT THEY COME UP
WITH.
OTHERWISE WE FIND OURSELVES ONCE
AGAIN IS THAT WE SHOULD AND THIS
IS ENOUGH DECISION [inaudible]
GOVERNOR FOR THIS COMMITTEE THAT
WE TAKE OUR TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ISSUES THAT ARE BEING
RAISED HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN TAKEN
THROUGH WITH SOME THOUGHT --
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO -- THE
UNFORTUNATE THING OF BEING IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
I MEAN LEGISLATURE PERIOD IS
THAT OFTENTIMES IS NOT ENOUGH
CONVERSATION.
IS NOT ENOUGH ACTUAL WORKING
COMMITTEES THAT ACTUALLY FOCUS
ON THESE ISSUES AND GIVE TIME
FOR IT TO HAPPEN OUTSIDE OF THE
REALM OF LEGISLATION.
AND I THINK THE ISSUE OF
CHARTERS IS SO IMPORTANT --
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW AND WITH
SUCH A TURNING POINT A CRITICAL
POINT OF FIGURING OUT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IN AND WE'VE BEEN
FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS OF WAR
CHARTERS.
WITHOUT REALLY CLEAR
CONVERSATION ACROSS THE BOARD
AND WE'VE WORKED INTO THINGS
THAT MAYBE WE DIDN'T WANT TO GO
INTO AND DIDN'T PRESERVE OF
THINGS WITH OVER IMPORTANT AND
ON AND ON THAT --
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMITTEE THAT'S
BEING FORMED BY THIS NEW
SUPERINTENDENT OF IN A PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
BLESSING OF I HOPE WE'LL HAVE
SOME GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS FOR US
BY THE BUT AT THE END OF THEIR
TURN TIME.
THAT WE CAN THEN USE THAT AS A
AS A A A PLATFORM FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF LEGISLATION THAT
WE THINK WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR
CHARTERS AND PUBLIC SCHOOLS AS
WE GO FORWARD.
AND THAT WE DON'T RUSSIA HERE
BUT I THINK THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS TIMES COME IT'S
BEEN UP MANY MANY TIMES BEFORE.
FORTUNATELY WHERE WITH A POINT
NOW WHERE THERE'S A AT LEAST
SOME UNDERSTANDING OF THE TWO
PARTIES THAT WORK TOGETHER AND I
AM SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL TODAY
BUT I HOPE THAT THE ISSUES THEY
RAISE WILL BE ALSO CONTINUING
THE DISCUSSION.
OF WHERE --
WHERE THERE MAY BE SOME
INEQUITIES THAT EFFECTIVELY --
WILL SUPPORT THIS ISSUE AS A
COME FOR TODAY IN THE CURRENT
FORM.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER --
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS --
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I CALL YOU GOT AND YOU HAVE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN A WHILE YOU KNOW
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO PUBLICLY
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR MAKING
THIS A PRIORITY.
I'VE SAT ON THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE FOR FOUR
YEARS AND A LOT OF THESE ISSUES
HAVE REALLY I THINK DERAILED US
FROM A LOT OF THE GOOD WORK THAT
WE COULD DO.
STUFF LIKE THIS REALLY SETS US
ON A GOOD COURSE TO START THE
YEAR BOTH IN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY AND WORK ON OTHER
ISSUES.
AND I WANT TO THANK BOTH PARTIES
BECAUSE SOMEONE WHO NEGOTIATED
FOR MANY YEARS IF EVERYONE WALKS
AWAY A LITTLE HAPPY AND A LITTLE
UNHAPPY IT MEANS THAT WE DID
GOOD NEGOTIATIONS I DON'T THINK
ANYONE'S WALKING AWAY.
FEELING THAT THERE WAS A WINNER
AND A LOSER AND ASSEMBLYMAN --
WOMAN WEBER THE TASK FORCE TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS TO DO WITH THE
FISCAL ISSUES AND THE SUIT THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
HAS BEEN AND IS THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING TO DATE.
SO I THINK EVERYONE WHO HAD A
HAND IN THIS IT'S JUST A REALLY
GOOD WAY TO START OFF THE THE
NEW YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND I I WANT TO
THANK A ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
WHO WORKED ON THIS --
YOU SPENDA LOT OF TIME ON THIS
ISSUE LAST YEAR WE DIDN'T GET TO
WHERE WE WANTED TO GET LAST YEAR --
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT LAST YEAR
BUT I WANT TO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
HIS HARD WORK ON THIS ISSUE --
AS WELL --
SO WITH THAT THE MOTION IS TO
PLAT TO PASS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WITH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS O'DONNELL
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
I SMITH.
SMITH I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I IT THE THE BILLS OUT
FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
GOOD JOB [inaudible]
ISRAEL HEARING.
ON THE ASSEMBLY SO.
THIS IS SOMEBODY